Yeah.
[inaudible] says,
what's up with all these struggles?
He says,
I've never seen such synchronicity,
man.
I don't know what to say about that.
I had some frog synchronicity occurrences earlier this year that just about made
me saint.
So I don't know.
I have,
I have no idea what to make of it.
Um,
you know why
it leaves me speechless that that's all I can say about that.
You know,
I do,
you'll need,
Carl Young had some strange ideas and one of them was synchronicity and all the
fact that things could line up in a way that seemed meaningful.
And you know,
much as I don't understand how that occurs,
I've experienced it many,
many times and then very convincing ways.
And so it's,
it's one of the things that leads me to think that the world isn't structured
the way that we think it is.
I think it's structured more like a symphony where,
where,
and there are times when dis different parts of the world,
different parts of being can come into harmony spontaneously and all pointed the
same direction and why that happens,
I have no idea.
All right.
I don't understand it at all.